hi everyone my name is hoi fung poon i'm
the senior director of biomedical nlp
in microsoft health futures today i'm
very excited to be here
to be giving this webinar with my
colleague jim von gao
who is a distinguished scientist at
microsoft research and also the partner
research manager of the deep learning
group
together we are going to present to you
our latest
advances in domain-specific language
model for training
for biomedical natural language
processing
so in the mainstream nlp the focus has
been on the general domain such as the
newswire
and the web and in recent years one of
the most exciting advances
is in the newer language model per
training
and there has been actually ongoing arm
raise in training error bigger models
with error larger text copper
many benchmarks and leaderboard have
been also created
so that we can evaluate those language
model and track the progress
by the community in biomedicine
on the other hand the landscape is quite
different
the biomedical texts such as pubmed
papers are very different from the
general main ones
however biomedical nlp has received
relatively little attention
in the mainstream nlp research for
example
the biomedical language models tend to
be a simple extension of the general
domain one
and there has been no existing
leaderboard for biomedical nlp
so in this webinar we are going to
present to you
a new paradigm that we have been
pursuing
to train language model for specialized
domains such as
biomedicine this has led us to produce
the pubmed birth
which has attained state-of-the-art
results in a wide range of biomedical
nlp
tests we'll also present to you the
blurb
which is a comprehensive benchmark and
also the first leaderboard for biomicro
nlp
in the first half of the talk uh i will
start by
sort of motivating biomedical nlp and
show how
it can help revolutionize about
biomedicine i will then contrast some of
the conventional paradigm for domain
specific
training which motivate our new uh
paradigm for pro training from scratch
uh the specialized uh biomedical
language model
i'll also explain a little bit uh why we
need a comprehensive benchmark
and the rationale behind the blue in the
second half
gen phone will walk you through the
practical side of the biomedical
language model for training including
department burp training
and i'll have to add comparison against
other births
and also across many task-specific
modeling choices so
as we mentioned earlier bio biomedical
nlp is quite different compared
to the mainstream nlp but it has been
relatively unexplored in the past
however
it can actually potentially have play a
very key role
in the emerging area of precision
medicine
so in the ideal world we want every
patient to be able to respond to the
treatment they have been prescribed to
and signified by the blue person on the
left of the graph here
in the real world unfortunately most of
the patients do not respond to the
treatment they have been prescribed
identified by the rep person here
so the this is obviously a well-known
problem for a long time but
in the past the challenge is that we use
not to have a lot of fine-grained
feature to be able to distinguish the
blue from the red
at priority so the event of big data in
medicine
promised a change for the good and
cancer is the poster trial for this
with the with the tumor
genomic sequence for example we are
literally staring at the source code for
the cancer
and can potentially distinguish
individual patients
down to the the individual level
another major disruption is the rapid
digitization
of the medical records which provide us
with fine-grained information
of longitudinal patient trajectories
so all these are very exciting but
the big data also present a grand
challenge of
information overload for example
the tumor genomics sequence doesn't buy
us anything
unless we can translate them and
interpret them
and actually turn them into actionable
insight for treating the cancer patients
currently this has been done completely
manually
by the so-called molecular tumor bore
which is obviously
not scalable a major bottleneck
for tumor board is to be able to
gather all those knowledge from the
literature such such as the knowledge
about the gene the mutation
and how they predispose the tumor uh
with respect to
a drug uh treatment regimen
so all this information is gathered in
the pubmed
paper which adds four thousand new paper
every day
and over a million every year
and similarly there has been a lot of
fine-grained information as we mentioned
earlier but they
actually get buried underneath all those
medical texts such as the clinical notes
a cancer patient can easily have
hundreds of nodes
which can take hours to curate all those
available information
so biomedical nlp can help by
enabling us to unlock those such
knowledge from the medical
biomedical tax at scale and thereby
facilitating clinical trial
and clinical care and research
from the literature we can extract
a pubmed scale knowledge graph where
the nodes are basically all these key
medical entities such as a drug
gene mutation disease and the edge or
hyper edges
are the relation among them such as drug
response
or genetic regulations and with all this
information
we can a salary progress in drug
discovery repurposing
as well as clinical decision support
such as
in the molecular tumor board from the
medical records
we one particularly exciting direction
is to
curate such a population level
real-world evidence
which capture the longitudinal
information about
the diagnosis treatment and outcome
information for
patients and this information can enable
us to facilitate
and greatly accelerate clinical trial
matching
post-market surveillance as well as
conducting
things like virtual trial that can
drastically reduce
the cost for drug development so
hopefully i have convinced you that
biomedical nlp can play a key role in
helping to
materialize the prospect of precision
health and
revolutionize biomedicine however
there have there are many steep
challenges for biomedical nlp
first of all people tend to have used
very different way to say
essentially the same thing so here are
just a few ways to state the simple fact
that the tumor suppressor p533
can inhibit the apoptosis pathway pcl2
in a small compass of a couple thousand
abstracts
there is already an extremely long tail
of words that can be used to signify
such negative regulations on the flip
side
the same expression can also mean
completely different things
so for example there is a gene called a
pdf
so as you can imagine about medical nlp
system
has to be able to disambiguate such gene
reference from other meanings such as
like the text format
or maybe some other acronym like privacy
density functions now obviously uh
variation and
ambiguity are the bread and butter nlp
challenges
but in biomedicine there are also
additional challenges that have been
received relatively little attention in
the mainstream nlp research
in the biomedic in biomedicine the most
valuable information
tend to exhibit little redundancy such
as the latest
medical findings such information
is often expressed in very complex
linguistic
way and if we um solve by
skipping some of those facts they could
literally mean
a life or death for some patients so we
have no choice but have to tackle such a
complexity head on so that we can leave
no fact behind
for example in in most of the
information extraction
research they tend to be focusing on
binary relation
within single sentences in
in biomedicine we tend to need to
extract
much more complex relation which can
span across
many many sentences for example in the
molecular tumor board
you might care about how would a tumor
with certain gene
and mutation would respond to
a particular drug regimen so such a
ternary relation can easily scan us
span across many paragraphs as you can
see in the example here
in biomedicine we also lose a very
powerful tool which is
the crowdsourcing so in mainstream nlp
it's a common practice to
have mechanical turkish to help produce
a very large
label dataset which can help
train the nlp systems
in biomedicine or other specialized
domain the challenge is that the average
worker tend not to have the domain
expertise
for to doing such an annotation task for
example you can imagine asking an
average turker
to read you know interpret a cancer
genetic paper for you
or interpret the ct scan that would be
pretty hard
now language model per training
represent one very powerful approach
to help alleviate such a annotation
bottleneck
unlike in the standard supervised
paradigm where the label example
becomes the bottleneck for the
supervised training
in the south so-called self-supervised
learning paradigm
what the key insight is that we can
leverage
the abundantly available unlabeled texts
and then essentially hallucinate some
noisy training data
in those unlabeled texts at scale so
that we can help bootstrap the learning
a newer language model represent a task
agnostic way
to do this kind of sales supervised
learning
given the unlabeled text essentially
what we are going to do
is to high pick just a random subset of
words to high
and then ask the language model to
predict them back
so by doing so we are forcing a language
model to capture a lot of those semantic
dependencies in the text
and thereby they can produce some very
meaningful features
to enable very efficient learning
for the downstream nlp tests
so such a neural language
model per training has attained a lot of
success
in the general domain so for specialized
domain like biomedicine
it's it's quite natural for folks to
start focusing on
you know uh um assuming that uh all this
general domain language model is still
quite helpful
and in fact the the standard mixed
domain per training paradigm
tend to essentially inherit the
vocabulary from the general domain
starting from the generic language model
before actually training with the in
domain text
so such a paradigm make perfect sense if
our target domain
has very little uh tax to to
use in per training and thereby in this
way we can
actually leverage the transfer learning
from the general domain text
to help a particular sort of
domain-specific
training in the biomedicine however
we observed that this rationale actually
start to break down
because we actually have plenty of the
unlabeled tags
in the in the bio medical text as we
mentioned earlier
pop map has over 30 million papers
and add over a million every year
so this has motivated us to start
looking at and actually
a new paradigm for per training uh
language model for such a specialized
domain
in which we actually general uh conduct
uh
per training entirely using in domain
text
and for example in this case we will be
actually conducting the
training with uh just the pump text
and we'll call the resulting language
model the palmetto
to see why this paradigm can
actually be advantageous
let's take a look at the vocabulary
which is a fixed size
set of frequent words and sub-words
on top of which where the language model
tried to learn to acquire
those meanings so only a very few
common biomedical terms occur frequently
enough in the general domain
so that they will be chosen into the
vocabulary
and be modeled as such first-class
citizens
so in on on the other hand many of the
other
uh words biomedical terms will instead
be shattered into
sort of essentially fragments
and then during the in domain training
the language model are forced to
basically learn using such
essentially meaningless fragments for
the biometric
context we should also keep in mind that
during the in-domain training per
training the language model
actually also have to essentially
unlearn a bunch of those
uh irrelevant
connotation from the general domain that
have nothing to do with the biomath code
domain so this is partially why
um why pretraining from scratch as we
are taken in the palmetto
approach can potentially be much more
superior to
the mixed domain per training and later
in the talk
as you can see this indeed results to
significant performance gain
in in many downstream manufactures
now to facilitate this study we have
created blur which is a comprehensive
benchmark for biomedical nlp
in in the in the past there have been
many data sets
and share tasks for biomats however
many of them tend to focus on
individual tasks a key advantage for
language model for training is that it's
essentially a universal way to
help a wide range of downstream nlp
tests
it is therefore imperative to create a
comprehensive benchmark so that we can
evaluate across
many biomedical uh nlp tests
so recently blue is
attempt to address this need but
the blue data set still have relatively
little
limited coverage for biomedical tasks
most importantly blue actually mixing up
the pubmed based biomedical tasks with
the mimic-based
clinical tests and as we can see later
these two domains even though they are
highly related
are still very very different so this
has motivated us to create blurb
which is shot for biomedical language
understanding and reasoning benchmark
our goal is to produce a comprehensive
and domain specific
benchmark so that we can facilitate
evaluation
on the biomedical language model per
training
as you can see it consists of 13 data
set
that's spanning six diverse tasks
which include name entity recognition
evidence-based
medical information extraction relation
extraction
sentence similarity document
classification
and question answering so
compared to uh prior work on uh
biomedical uh per training
the blur is uh is uh is the most uh
comprehensive
so this concludes the first half of the
talk and i will pass on to jen fern who
will
walk you through the practical side of
biomedical language model per training
hello i'm jim finkel from microsoft
research
in the second part of the talk i will
present
permit bird which is a domain-specific
portraying language model for biomedical
nlp
and we will also present some comparison
results between
permanent birth and other patron models
using the
benchmark we are releasing the training
models
and the benchmark for the community to
help
accelerate the research
let's see how the pubmed model is
trained
unlike the widely used mixed maple
training approach
where a language model is often first
portrayed
using general domain text such as
newswire and the web text and then
continually
portraying using target domain data
permit bird is portraying using target
domain data
from scratch the target domain data here
are a collection of permit papers
our measure is motivated by a few
considerations
first mix the domain per training is a
form of transfer
learning where the general domain data
is assumed to be
helpful for the applications in the
target domain
because the target data is scarce
and the general domain is assumed to be
relevant
to the target domain but this is not the
case
for the biomedicine domain where the
biomedical data
or text is very different from
general domain text and then we have
large amounts of permit papers
for the make specific training we will
show in a minute
that the domain specific training from
scratch
substantially outperforms continuous
training of general economic models
thus demonstrating that the prevailing
assumption
in support of mixed makeup training is
not always
applicable our domain-specific
training takes two steps first we
generate a in-demand vocabulary
from perma papers this vocabulary
contains many common biomedical
terms which are not included in the
vocabulary
used by most of the general recognition
models
as harvang should in his power then
we portraying perma earth using the
standard
mask language model objective
we mask a few words in the text and the
trend
the model to recover these words given
the context
now let's see how the model performs
in this table we compare a permanent
birth against
some of the existing state-of-the-art
trend language models
around four dimensions vocabulary
per training measures the domain and the
size of the training data
well we noticed that the birth and the
robota
are general domain language models and
the vocabulary and the models
are learned from wiki data
from both corpus and the web data
robota has trained a much larger
terminator and
a small robust than earth across many
nlp tasks
and the bird biobit clinical bird
bluebird are all trained using mixed
domain per training
they are initialized by birth and then
continually portraying
using biomedical text
note that in the continuous training
approach the vocabulary is the same
as the original word model in this case
the one generated from wikipedia and
book corporates
why convenient this is a major
disadvantage
of this approach as the vocabulary is
not
representative of the target biomedicine
biomedical domain cybert is a notable
exception
as it generates the vocabulary and the
portraying
from scratch using biomedicine and the
computer science papers
however from the perspective of
biomedical applications
cybert still adopts the
mixed domain for training approach
because the
computer science papers are
clearly auto domain the version of
pubmed
we use for compression use the training
data that contains
perma paper abstracts
which amounts to 3.1 billion words
we perform two types of comparison
first we fix the task specific modules
for each downstream task and compare
different
trainer language models second
we fix the trend language model and
compare different
task specific model choices for each
task
in both cases we find human home models
here is the general architecture of
fine-tuning a patreon language model
for downstream applications
first an input instance
is processed by a transform
bay a transform input module which
performs
task specific transformations such as
indominifirring entity mentions
for relation detection then the
transform the input is tokenized
using the vocabulary and the fed into
the language model
next the contextual representation at
the top
layer is processed by
a visualizer module and then fed into
the predict
module to generate the final output for
a given task
to compare language models
we fix all the task specific modules as
highlighted in this figure
note that architecture of the visualizer
is
fixed but the parameters are updated
together with the rest of the language
model
during fine tuning
now we compare all training models by
applying them
to the downstream energy tasks
in blur for each task
we conducted the same fine-tuning
process
using the standard task specific models
we can see that by conducting the most
basic
training from scratch per map
consistently
outperforms all the other bird models
in most bioenergy tasks
often by a significant module
the gains are most substantial against
the bird
and the robotic models trend using
general domain text
most notably why the training corpus
used by robota is the largest
its performance on bio unlimited tasks
is among the worst
similar to the original model
the models using medical
text in per training generally perform
better
however the mixed out domain data
input training generally leads to worse
performance
in particular as evidenced by the
results of clinical birth
and the bluebird even though the
clinical notes
are more relevant to the biomedical
domain
than general domain text anything
does not introduce any improvement
like permeable cyborg is also trained
from scratch
but it uses mixed domain data for
training
so it significantly underperforms
permanent birth
not surprisingly firebird
is the closest to permanent birth as
it also used permit text for per
training
but initialized using birth however
we see that by conducting domain
specific training from scratch
including using the permit vocabulary
method obtains consistent gains
over by birth
we also tried adding full text articles
from pmc as per training data
the training data is much much larger
than the pubmed
abstracts surprisingly
this leads to slightly performance
decrease
there are several reasons since the
the full text contains more noise than
abstract and the most
un bioenriched tasks are based on
abstracts
so the full text may be slightly out of
domain
moreover even if four tests are
potentially helpful
additional training cycles are needed
it turns out by extending per training
for
60 percent longer the overall results
slightly outperform the standard
per permanent birth trend only on
abstracts
and we leave it to future work to
explore
how to more effectively leverage full
text
data next we study the effect
of modeling choices in task-specified
tuning
by fixing the underlying portraying
language model
to our standard parameter
prior to the success of patreon language
model
standard nlp approach were dominated by
sequential labeling models such as
air stm now with the use of the self
attention mechanism
the top layer in both already captures
many non-linear dependencies
across the entire text band therefore
it's conceivable
that even a simple linear layer on top
can perform competitively when we find
that
this is indeed the case for
name entity recognition or and yeah
and relation extraction tasks as shown
in this table
the use of bi-directional astm
does not significantly outperform a
linear layer
the use of neural measures also has
subtle but significant implications for
radiation
detection previously relation detection
was generally framed as a classification
task
with manually crafted feature templates
and to avoid overfitting the templates
typically avoid using any
entities in question
neural measures do not use handcrafted
features
but use the neural encoding of the given
test span
including the entities themselves these
thus
introduce a potential risk that the
neuronal models may
simply memorize the entity combination
as a result it is a common practice to
identify
entities for example by replacing an
entity with a generic tag
we just conduct a systematic evaluation
of entity gamification
and relation coding using radiation
extraction tasks as example
as shown in this table simply using the
original text is the worst
due to overfitting gamification remains
the most reliable measures
interestingly using both the entity
marks and dummification
leads to slightly better results but it
appears to prevent overfitting while
preserving
useful entity information
now we are releasing the trained permit
models and benchmark to public
our goal is to accelerate research
on bioenrapie by lowering the
entry barriers facilities
reproducibility
and tracking community progress
given the importance of the bio nlp we
encourage researchers around the world
to participate
starting by evaluating your models
on the benchmark brochure is a
collection
of resources of conducting bioenergy
research
we have created the first bioenergy
readable welcome to submit the results
of your models or systems
and we also upload the trend
per map models to hacking to the hotend
fixed side
and the model has more than 1000
downloads in the first week
our future work includes further
exploration of domain-specific training
strategies
incorporating more tasks into
biomedicine
unlp by medical nlp and extension of the
broader benchmark
to clinical and other high value domains
thank you
hi everyone
hi everyone uh
uh this is hakshan pun and uh welcome to
the webinar
and jinfang do you want to do something
yeah yeah this is a champion
so welcome to our talk now it's the
uh not qa time we receive a lot of great
questions and try to answer
all of them as much all at least as much
as we can
i want that question to corey
goes through the questions and we
jointly
and provide answers okay just go ahead
yeah sure um so there are a bunch of
great questions and
we have answered a few in the chat let's
see
um one one of the
uh really good question is about that
um would it make sense to portray a
model
on a combination of multiple copies like
and is it uh the main problem is
computation costs or does this depends
on the target domain
um i would say that uh computation cost
is one factor
right but uh if you don't care about
computing costs and
only care about performance the real
question is depends on your
applications if you if your application
is so open-ended
like you don't know where your next
instance come from right for example
you're doing open domain qa you don't
know where whether the next question
will be like in general domain or in
medic medicine and so forth
in that case it it makes sense to train
a more broad coverage
language model so that you cover as much
as possible
but if you know ahead of time your
application is actually
uh in a specific target domain uh then
it in that case is
it it could be a beneficial to
train that uh language model just for
that target domain
questions can you also give me the
number of the questions
so i can follow it easily yeah so the
the
question i just uh answered is like uh
seven
number seven um
yeah that's good let's move
yeah and and then there is a question
like uh
is the pubmed verb portraying on data
that's
used in the pubmed qa task
so so the pubmed model is portraying on
all the pubmed and if
that would actually uh
include all the abstracts so that that
would basically include
definitely the test uh the text in the
in the pubmed qra task
one thing to be clear is that the per
training is only have access to the
unlabeled text
so it doesn't actually have any uh
label information that's pretty standard
in the upper training
uh uh question number nine is also very
interesting
it says apart from the permit source
uh have you tried the utilizing
biomedical specific
knowledge graphs and to enhance these
birds
and do you think that will be helpful in
mathematical domain and therapy it's a
great question
we are thinking about around the same
line but at the moment
the permeability is trend without
leveraging any
uh knowledge graph this is definitely
our future work
and we already started trying to use
the transformer to encode knowledge
graphs in a small scale
and see pretty promising results yeah
definitely we're going to leverage
the knowledge graph because knowledge
graph probably
a more informational than play text
in some sense so the then the the
challenging research questions are how
we leverage about
do we do curriculum learning or
or simply combine these dates
that data source for example we can
generate a text
from the knowledge graph and then then
just combine
the the train data okay yeah
that's a very good question we we we
hope we can get some results pretty soon
okay
thank you
yeah and then yeah and then question
uh number 11
quantitative value also encoded in this
model
the quantitative numbers are often very
important for the medical case
this is a great question right now we
don't do any special
encoding so we simply treat it as
just another you know character stream
so
it will be broken into software just
like any other words
so it there are definitely some
domains and applications where this kind
of value actually get into
very important for example one
particular example
that we have been uh noticed is in the
pathology right for example for cancer
pathology report
or radiology report when they start to
talk about you know how big the tumor
size is right what's the dimensions and
so forth
um those are actually direct those
numbers are directly
uh related to you know for example
whether the patient is on stage two or
stage three
and so forth um so so in
in those cases actually the standard
encoding is actually not doing a very
good job so
so it's actually uh for
specific application we have tried
actually more specialized
encoding but in general it's actually a
great area to look at
yeah okay the next question 12
is about evaluation when you say that
pubmed
outperforms other matters do you have
any statistical analysis to support
your statement and yes if you read the
paper whenever we mention that this
result this improvement is significant
that means and we run some sort of
significant test
but for many cases uh since the
evaluation they say is pretty large
so uh and the improvement margin is
is is big enough so most of the
improvements are statistically
significant
not by chance thank you
yeah we also um we also assessed the
um the standard deviation and exactly
what jenkins said like
many of these datasets are actually uh
big enough uh certainly there are some
exceptions right like biosis
that that's relatively small and but
for most of them actually if you look at
the standard deviation and
you can see that the gap is actually
more than that
so hopefully you want to take the next
and
got a lot of questions we should speed
up right so
um yeah maybe question uh 13
uh so the vocabulary update
is important uh when comparing palmetto
and bioware that are both trained on
pubmed also the initial
pro training model of course what role
does the server technique
like were piece play here great question
so we actually use the standard
workpiece
algorithm to generate vocabulary now
keep in mind that biobar actually adopts
the continual per training approach so
so it's actually based on the standard
birth so it actually
by doing that it it it's restricted to
the standard bur
uh vocabulary um so so
um and um and
so so there's actually the comparison
exactly like you said
like the the key difference is actually
solved in the vocabulary
um and the software techniques so far we
haven't tried a whole lot different
variant
and we don't suspect that will be
a big difference um but but that's
that's a good question
uh the next question um 14
14 why do we think a case models general
perform better in
um bio unlikely task uh
yeah i i i don't know particularly the
reason the
but the difference between one case in
the case in many tasks are
not that big uh however do you have any
good answer to this question
yeah i i think the sort of the
um case uh the advantage one case is
that
your your vocabulary actually you can
cover
some of a bigger uh uh
because you basically ignore the case
difference right now
intuitively uh uh so some of the bio nlp
tasks like entity recognition right ner
you feel intuitively the case actually
matters
but just like jennifer mentioned like we
actually tried casement case
and we don't see a whole lot of
difference so what we suspect what
happened is that
in even for ner the context matter a lot
more than just the case information
right so then and the young case has the
advantage that the vocabulary can
capture
a lot more you know things because
because like
it basically ignore the case difference
okay next question 15 is vocabulary
difference
the biggest difference between domains
or is it more the linguistics
how do you tease out the difference
between the two
it really depends on the model first of
all i think vocabulary is
so far the the biggest difference
between domains as for the linguistics
here really depends on
what level of linguistics uh
it's the phrase level whatever pressure
of sentence level document level
so far because all these models
do not capture linguistic structures
explicitly so my
hypothesis is that even if there's a
significant difference in linguistic
structure
it may not be reflected in the model so
back to the question
and the answer is yes given the current
model a current study
i think the biggest difference among
domains is vocabulary
thank you as well
yeah so the the next one is like can you
please give some guidance about
making question answering system using
biomedical research papers
that's a great question so frankly we
have think quite a bit about qa
for biomap we are
sort of like somewhat so
uncertain about sort of like how big an
impact a qa system so there are some
clear case where the qa
seems to be make a lot of sense right
but also biomedical
often it's like uh have
such a characteristic where you in each
of the specific domain let's say
oncologies or
or cardiologists and so forth right you
often
know ahead of time so like what are the
questions the real
challenge is actually finding a lot of
the scaling to find a lot of the answer
like for example for cancer like what
are the
most important genetic mutation and what
are the treatment that could potentially
target them
um so in some sense like sort of like
you have you know half time when your
question
often are the most important question
right so
so it's more about actually extracting
those knowledge and and information
uh the next question number 17
how can the nfp extend into clinical
practice
and applications uh i would say so far
uh the energy technology as we
demonstrate
uh in the talk and in your paper uh is
mainly playing a role
of assistant and they are not going to
replace our daughters
think at this moment uh this
system is helping to you know summarize
the
the the large amount of documents
identifying
key points and then send a summary of
this
all these coupons to the doctor to
review or help doctors
identify relevant information for larger
amounts of
documents or records so it's mainly an
assistant bro okay
yeah just to echo gentleman's point um
one thing
one thing we think that the the biggest
we spot we can nlp or ai in general can
play
is like this self-assisted sort of
curation
um so normally in any place where
you need a lot of human effort to review
lots and lots of
you know like for example clinical notes
right like a patient could have hundreds
of
notes um and and so the technology can
potentially
uh narrow that down to you know a few
candid candidate places uh with the
candidate
answer or information you're looking for
and and exactly what jim vong said like
we are not
imagining like we can get to the
accuracy to automate the whole thing
but we can potentially substantially cut
down the human
uh manual efforts
i i can probably answer in this one it's
about does that makes uh
18 does it make sense sometimes to mask
i guess it's name entities and then
continue to training yeah
it does make sense and the informal
applications it helps
but we're not we have not
run extensive studies experiments in our
paper and this is related to the
so-called
spam birth or entity per
but people already should demonstrate
some benefits
using this approach in general domain
you want to put yeah the next thing
yeah the next question is like most of
the medical documents are long
and how do you account for representing
this larger document during language
modeling and later using it for
downstream
tests and this is a great question um
and
one thing as gen phone actually alluded
to earlier
um actually there has been a lot of
recent interest in sort of like doing
this long range
you know uh modeling right like uh uh
expanding the self-attention to a much
longer range
um it it's actually some of the
challenging
uh challenges are actually twofold one
is like
we definitely need a lot more of those
research
into how do we actually represent those
large documents
larger contacts but also
for the evaluation right now i would say
a lot of those public available tasks
are still relatively focused on the
local phenomenon linguistic phenomena
right often
time they may even be a single sentences
so so there is probably also a need
to actually go to some of those
end-to-end scenarios to figure out tasks
that actually reflect and truly require
this kind of bigger
context modeling and in medicine
actually there are indeed
a lot of those uh use cases right in
some of our own work
like we look at uh cross paragraph
course sentence
relation extraction uh and when you go
to a clinical domain
you often have like a patient you
actually
need to look at information across
different nodes
right like not even a single document
like multiple
documents so so there is absolutely a
lot of need to model
a much bigger context but also one of
the bottlenecks right now
for the research community is the
evaluation
so i think i can take the next three
questions
i think uh number
20 based on your presentation is a
better approach to build
specific models from the scratch rather
than adopting
general pre-trained models uh as we
mentioned in the
in the in the in the presentation it
really depends
um we find that beneficial to trend
model
patreon model from scratch if the domain
is dramatically different
from the general domain and there's a
large amount of
income data okay that is the case
of the of the pubmed
so uh next question 21
patient generating
patient generated information became
patients sorry patient generated
information becomes very important
in advancing medical practice
much of this information is on social
media how does your
member perform our social media data oh
that's
interesting question we we don't have
the result yet
but social media data is is off by
wide variety so uh it depends on the
task right if we define
uh uh uh
bio biology related task on
social media data and the data is very
selective
for the task then i bet that the model
performs better
than the general but model
yeah next question hi and
and question to nato uh kind of
thanks for the great event
i am currently a
research student and finally i worked
pretty interesting i was wondering
whether i'm
able to contribute to any of your
projects
if you are a student and we have msr has
internship
and you can apply and feel free to apply
online
or send email to google ni or see
if there's an opportunity thank you
great um so maybe i would take the next
few questions um so
was publisher pay wars and ip an issue
when working with biomedical nlp domain
so great question that's absolutely a
problem
so in pubmed abstract you can have
access to all 50 million
but for full tags there are only
sort of a bug download portion that
currently i think is then about
three million of them right um so
and and there is a lot a lot of
full text article that i saw uh saw
lockdown in the in the pay wars
because of that so right now we don't
frankly that's a societal problem or
business
question so right now we are mostly
focusing on the publicly accessible one
um and certainly uh
would be great if we can come come to a
solution to
uh uh extend the
uh the training and access to
beyond the pay wars um there are
certainly individual solutions to that
so what the next question what would be
approach for
continuous improve world improvement of
the model with the availability of new
research
this is fantastic question so
it's basically like sort of imagining
like you have
already changed your language model
right on 30 million primary paper
but frankly pubmed had 20 000
each week right so um new papers so
um so so online continue per training
actually would be
actually a very uh exciting area we
haven't done a whole lot in that area
but
but there there are some obvious
strategies to go about that
um but but this is a great area to look
at
another question along with pubmed is
there any way we can get the latest live
information from doctor treating patient
frankly as we alluded to in the earlier
of the talk
uh there are there are basically a big
portion of medical text is from pubmed
right from the literature but there is
also
a lot of information exactly as they
alluded to
uh come from actually doctor's notes
right so there is this concept about
real world evidence that we alluded to
in the talk
uh that is become a very exciting area
which is like what if
you can also not only see all the
latest consensus knowledge from the
literature
and sort of like have this pubmed scale
knowledge graph but also
have a population level real world
evidence like
getting all the longitudinal information
from patients and so forth
so and from that you can actually derive
a lot of insight
and help prioritize hypothesis and
potentially
substantially cut down on the drug
development cost
so i guess i will
take one more then then you
you will do the 27 cm i can do 27 28
yeah
okay so let me do the 26 then um do you
have
done some analysis on how vocabulary
being
tokenized what's the best strategy to
evaluate
um so a good question so
we use the standard workpiece algorithm
to
essentially look at the corpus and find
essentially you can think about this
find the most frequent
subset of subwords right to best
represent the
copper so that you don't have to shatter
everywhere into
characters and so forth so there is
frankly a lot more things to be done to
compare different
vocabulary strategies especially if you
are
not like jennifer mentioned right like
there are not always the case
to portraying from scratch so if you are
in the middle of it
like your uh what what's the best way to
like look at the vocabulary we have some
more ongoing research and
and this is a fascinating area
uh so it takes uh 27 28
27 and do you think it's possible to
implement
another pe to geometric sequence data
map building now world as a sequence of
specific
pertaining binding sites or it's a
very interesting question and actually
the answer is yes
and i'm sure there are already many
ongoing efforts
and doing this people start with
sequence sequence models
for this sequential labeling task
i don't remember specific papers but i'm
sure there are papers
already reporting yeah there are a
couple
yeah there are not a whole lot yet but
uh there are a couple papers looking at
that
right and now
number 28 oh it's a bunch of questions
uh could you clarify a little bit uh
that
it is a base or large-sized model uh
i think we reviewed both models and base
size model underneath size model
actually we made both models public
comparables through hacking case
sites so you can go there and download
these two models
also what do you think in general
domain specific training how relevant is
a fully
domain specific vocabulary
or relevant is a fully domain specific
vocabulary
and did you meet ank tokens
for example using models with not from a
specific vocabulary
uh i want to clarify uh
to train models like birds
and other similar models and the
vocabulary is
support vocabulary so there's no
bunk because it's a
uh it's a character sequence uh the the
unit is currency in the in the in the
extreme case uh you think that the the
we can always decompose a word into a
sequence
of characters and all these characters
if all these characters are in the
category so there's no
od in general term
i don't want more could you let me know
what kind of training method
you use oh everything is standard we
follow the same training uh procedure as
a bullet maybe microsoft steep speed
solution of the suggestion
but in this study we haven't used the
microsoft experience
okay maybe i can take off uh the next
few um do you plan to include any entity
linking tasks in blue
uh absolutely that's that's uh there are
several
uh kind of uh uh sort of like additional
data set we are
very interested in adding anti-linking
definitely being one of them
we also like we mentioned a little bit
earlier
we are also really interested in finding
the tasks that are more sort of like
tailored to
really end-to-end scenario uh and also
that often require more sophisticated
linguistic
you know modeling uh where you can
really start to come
compare uh some of those per training
like for example one question earlier
people asking about long range modeling
modeling longer
context longer document you also saw
really neat uh evaluation to actually
meet that cell at long range
so some of the tasks that people are
looking at like
qa or you know multi-hop qa and start to
actually go in that direction so so
absolutely like the current
blur version is just the starting point
um
based on my the next question based on
my
biometh research experience usually
applications for protein and locates for
genes that
do add this information as a feature as
a model
uh frankly uh like we said earlier like
for ner right like the case information
intuitively
are very uh relevant um and
uh but what we find that is actually the
uncased model actually performed roughly
the same as the case actually slightly
better
the reason is that on balance on the n
case by ignoring the case
you have a more you know a
focused vocabulary um that and and then
you'll
still get a lot of information from the
context uh frankly the
upper case for protein lowercase for
gene actually as far as i understand
like
that's not even true uh universally
right like
it uh sometimes it's like uppercase for
human genes
and a lowercase for mice genes uh and so
it's it's a it's a mess
right so um so the case is solve a
double-edged sword
in some sense uh and empirically we find
that on case model actually perform just
fine
um but but you're totally right like
there is some information there that
might be worth taking further um how the
next question how power member helping
current code with
pandemic situation actually jeffrey and
i
have active workstream on code with
biomedical search
where we haven't have published the
result yet but
we have found that actually public
substantially
outperform a bunch of those uh standable
uh in uh in a biomedical research so
uh in the covi context um so on some of
the official
evaluation like track codes and so forth
and i just want to add then hopefully
very soon we're going to make the
commerce search
engine publicly available
which is empowered by a permanent bird
so probably i can take the next three
questions uh how do
the perma birth base work integrate with
the large
project hanover work
and how can this be extended into
clinical trials
matching based problems are you
requiring a better person to answer this
question
yeah so so um um so
palmetto is really can serve as the
basis for a lot of the biomedical nlp
um and and project handler really saw
focus on
uh sort of like uh also the application
side
right so as you alluded to like the
clinical trial matching
um so a lot of this uh application
uh what they fundamentally need is this
machine reading capability right you
need to unlock the knowledge and
information all right like you need to
unlock the
knowledge from the literature you need
to unlock the patient information from
the medical record
now once you are able to do that then
you can enable
empower a bunch of applications right so
for drug discovery for example
they can benefit a lot from primary
scale knowledge graph
for clinical trial matching you can
benefit from you know
be able to have you know all the
detailed patient information
uh from you know from from like millions
of cancer patients right like in your
hospitals and so forth
so i think we should go
faster let's wrap up okay okay sure
yeah maybe let me get the next one and
then jump from you you do the next few
um sometimes some medications are
allergic or harmful to
a few patients that who have other
medical history how to
how to do plan to overcome that
challenge when we predict the outcome
um fantastic question so in fact this
actually touched on a larger theme about
real
evidence which is like uh often time
when
the material company develops a drug
right and then you start to do clinical
trial
you are trying to uncover some of those
hours event that you mentioned about
right
but those trials have limited size right
even like large phase three
like maybe like kobe vaccine right that
that it's only like twenty thousand
thirty thousand patients right and
that's a
one of the largest one right and normal
uh
treatment actually you often have three
thousand four thousand
and so forth so you often meet some of
those like you know rare
you know allergic events or errors event
and that's where the promise is that if
we can actually
unlock all those information from the
medical records right from the medical
history as they alluded to
but one of the big bottlenecks there is
actually manual
abstraction manual curation is really
not scalable
right so so that's where and actually
potential nlp could
help scale scale
okay let's
see four following on
following on from the long non-argument
discussion
how do you deal with tests larger than
uh five
twelve tokens to an opportunity are we
simply
truncated to five 12.
next question 35 with clean nose
there um there may be
short hands and abbreviations not a
proper grammars
beyond permit what
how do we address these problems
actually through contextual embedding we
try to
uh link these shorthands and the
evolution
to the uh prop concepts
yes so contextual mating this is the
whole idea of using portraying that
language model
probably can take next two then we
okay sure um so how do you
systematically evaluate
domains that are different is there some
metric we can use
a great question so one actual thing
that very easy to do
is that you can run workpiece to
generate a
vocabulary on different domains and then
you can
look at the overlap you can see that
actually general domain
uh compared to pubmed for example like
the vocabulary overlap could be as low
as like 20 to 30 percent so so that's
one metric you can look at
um and certainly there are a lot other
uh uh aspect too
uh and then next question my future blur
in cool it's the same question as asked
before like uh
uh what about entity linking and other
uh
absolutely so we we definitely are
envisioning expanding the blur
uh benchmark so i think i think it's a
time to wrap
up um so uh thank you very much uh thank
you all for coming it's uh it's
up like these are all wonderful
questions
yeah thank you bye
okay bye everyone and and there was some
of the resource
page if you want to follow up and look
at
later